l'uomo saprebbe bari e benvenuti a
questo nuovissimo video di minecraft con
il mio amico pietro che sta qua che
ricorda picchiarlo
a proposito di viaggio qua io
nell'ultimo livello trovato il terzo
diamante però dobbiamo stare attenti
quattro ore il quarto ragazzi mancano
credo tre livelli perché effettivamente
esso parkour erano in totale sono segno
contati
qui mancano questo quello della lava
laggiù e poi questo quadri così
all'ultimo che è il mondo le land non ho
idea di come proseguire la cosa come
fatto fatta roba saltando a caso ti sei
fatta di pasqua sopra bravissimo sì che
le perfette avevamo capito neanche una
favola sull'albero amiche macoris al
vero o no e non lo so non lo so ha
guardato da e vabbè e da lì a minchia
figo alzano sempre stata
no no no no è giusto giusto giusto è
giusto quello di fatto finati vai avanti
esatto peraltro non ci credo esatto ma
yes.life solid snake in the albero 9
maggio benefici e morante bignami che
grazie a diamante e matri non c'è
nient'altro da noi dal segreto questo
non la guarda ma guarda qua si ferma sai
cos'è che ho capito nel corso del tempo
giocando a minecraft che se tu guardi in
alto salto in alto o è una mia
impressione ma almeno prima funzionato
sia mi chiedevi aprirlo se noi ho finito
torna subito indietro veloce per
qualcosa è sceso però lancia ha bisogno
ma stoner che ti ringrazio per conto mio
now
la proposta è stata aperta passiamo a
diventar matti questa è veramente facile
da fare
allora signori questo che imprese si
trasformerà in happy meals veramente
presto porca di una vacca è possibile ci
ho fatto ciò fatto affari intesa e tesa
ce la faccio ci sei
va bene la sensibilità e cosa dobbiamo
fare qua impazziti ok nola marzo cioè
fattami che ci ho fatto l'ho fatto ho
fatto ma è bravo come i possibili nel
non riesco mi fermo sempre troppo ridere
a quel salto io mi fermo non ce l'ha
fatta
dove vado quando e vorrei dirtelo ma
siccome non ho mai visto quella parte di
mappa gli ragione pure tu aspetta un
attimo chiaro che se mandarli sarà molto
crisi le premesse meno male non c'erano
blocchi chalamy che ci vediamo come
cacchio fai tu a trovare subito la
strada di tutto a di qui liquidity day
sull'albero soprano non c'è ma sopra
caso io ma come soprano amiche non
voglio che ne so ma scusami
ma tu ci ho creduto caso ea volte ha
senso negli anni è bravissimo proprio
così bravo
ora di là non ci ha spinto perché ci
abbiamo messo sei ore sono veramente
comunque che ci portava dentro c'è una
lampada qualcuno la lampada ma
soprattutto questo niente dal tanto
attesa cacchio va bene così lo ha capito
che fanno sulle torce possibile o no no
ti prego ghiaccio e torce centro 40 anni
però la neve la neve non è un problema
il resto se il problema è il creatore di
questo livello
madonna no ragazzi impossibile ok ma io
non mi ricordo più
gli azzurri però dai piace veramente
orribile ragazza ghiacci visto giappone
per il parco ghiaccio la cote nonni
slime con l'ancora divertente di
ghiaccio impossibile che ti sposta ruby
come vuole cioè impossibile la guarda ma
siamo sicuri che si debba fare così
perfetto io non ce l'avrei anche fatta
c'è il potere non sono neanche mai
arrivato ralph lauren weight
come hai fatto da qui non ci credono
siamo dei bar ma siano dei vincoli amici
ma cosa ma veramente scusa scusami ma ma
va a cagare sono due ore che prova era
era un bel roba lì non sapeva niente
o forse se no non può esservi ma non
serve a nulla
ma scusami ma è bravo bravissimo solo
fortissimo sul mangiato sono bravissima
e vitalità bravo secondo me non ce n'era
non se n'erano accorti loro o se ne sono
accorti semplicemente ci hanno preso per
il culo bravi grazie a tutti per aver
visto la provata di minecraft di oggi
che questa non rispettava le periferiche
dei fenomeni siamo una forza incredibile
sono qua non saprei ma non è ma neanche
so come sto facendo quello che sto
facendo
un fenomeno no ce l'hai fatta sei anni
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
ok poi conto che quanto apple non ora
come accomuna i tre citati bravo bravo
bravo bravo io non so detto soft key e
vabbè un casino bella no
dami che presentò il bottone qua da
qualche parte dove eccolo non può
schiacciare ho paura di fare l'ultimo
salto rischio solo qua non riesco
giovata rete livello cipe de tercia
michele dato a vedere se c'erano
diamanti serie ci arriva ok hai fatta
l'ho visto che non c'è niente qua però
da quando gli anni sei qui turelo prova
ho provato questo che uno slime qua
attenzione che ci sarai magma flop però
va bene un chip andranno anche santis
con occhio però occhio per occhio perché
qui c è partito in quinta c'era tempo ne
frega niente
quando come noi non stavo sorgere o non
penso che le cose siano lo so io ok va
bene allora non facciamo a mo di sfida
run non facciamola modi speedrun però
parsimoniosamente se ti poni scena da
fuoco mentre mi turba il fuoco e poi il
livello profondo tra poco ma non prendo
con loro perchè no ok ti perché veloce
saluto
ma cosa dici ma no fa ti prende in giro
mica per un attimo c'è anche creduto
vado a questa sta dicendo a kakà the ok
ciao ciao
e va bene se come veloce quella parte
non la fai torino
ti metti sotto e mi dai un calcio
funzione funzione bravi e vabbè mi
crederete ma bene niente fenomeno era
lanciatissimo terribile gol ce l'ha
fatta senza la schiavone mi sento utile
bravo
vediamo se tu sei morto 62 volte come
vice carlo gnocchi era di prima ci ha
influito negativamente sia un fenomeno
come come ecco le mani e aspetta che poi
è no aspettami che questo ancora più
difficile guida poi mi hai mentito ce
l'ho fatto la donna no non ci posso
veramente pensare che sono caduto così
ma non ti arrabbi niente se pensi che
ormai è quasi bello e così fico perché
sai che sei da quando è vero poi che non
sapevamo di avere ma che non ci
meritavamo
siamo attenti nel livello siamo attenti
nel livello successivo perché
probabilmente ci sono anche così
annuncia la seconda o terza volta che
succede sta roba
esatto pdv quanto pare aveva riportiamo
questa ormai siamo qua ragazzi pensato a
fare tutto questa cosa da buy a
diventare matti e se non c'era questa
cosa qua
tra domani però cesaro aspetto
tranquillo fate un salto
carissimo prodi civica minicar non
stiamo cercando di fare questo da un'ora
è stato zitto e non mi stanno aumentando
perché mi stanno concertando nel farlo
ok io benedettissimo 6 a noi andiamo
avanti avanti avanti avanti avanti sotto
sotto sotto sotto che ciò che dopo
anch'io propria saltare questa volta un
aspetto tecnico centrando già fatta
amico ok
mamma mia
ok bravissimo l'ultimo comico morina di
nuovo per far ridere tutti quanti ma non
è successo a spettacolo vedere se c'è
qualcosa da questo ha mostrato mentre lo
stato non certo a perché felici possiamo
andare notava capisco però è esatto
ma più che altro la televisione a non
cascare all'indietro qualche un macello
ritiro
no ma secondo me non è più che altro
secondo me dice tu cosa qui sotto
non si può passare ho fatto una roba che
non saprei di farla quindi se non e non
si può fare ciò fa tappa in diagonale
e una aspetta oddio non crea alcuna se
cadi dove devo andare
sì credo li ne sono sicurissimo
perché poi modo a ok ok che sì sì vado
lì su una donna e casinò ok madonna
regalo
ok mammamia rega che sogno e ora mi
chiama dovevano aspettare sono solo da
dovere ma complicata faccenda che hanno
capito il sì però molto io perché
continua accademy sono saltato
non ho saltato mannaggia a me e chi ma
crea 9 scheva i bravi
ecco adesso vieni qua che facilissimo
questo ma a me ma gli va data lei pipe e
tu non ci credono molto male sto male
pazzesco pazzesco incredibile pazzesco
favoloso pazzesco e adesso va bè ragazzi
aiuto non so se andare direttamente la
coppa
io non ho idea poco a lato era giusto
era giusto ma anche tutt'altro salto era
vecchi se ne frega mai
ma scusi ma mi metti un clock più
personale ma porca vacca ma ti pare ma
per fare così direttamente la puoi fare
no no lì non ci possa dire
no non è di qua liquami che ok e il
blocco se ci sarà un blocco nascosta da
qualche parte lo so no quelle diamante
stiamo cercando la combine vediamo hai
fatto questo no ma sentite to be to be
aspetta che arrivò anche sei ok
come faccio a fare questo è diviso tra
l'ultimo ok ma no scusa amico e non l'ho
fatto lo giuro che non l'ho fatto
apposta
però va bene mi aspetto che deve già in
voi vorrei farlo per tutti e due vorrei
capire com'è giusto guarda è giusto
davis e tutto questo sempre salire sopra
staccionata e grazie avevo capito anche
io ma devo andare sull'altra staccionata
ok per chi deve andare qui sotto mi
infondono in fondo ci riserviamo il
lavoro che faccio non devo passare
all'esterno non sono mai stato
dell'omissione ok madonna e casinò o si
ce l'ho fatta a sisimico alico rigoni
che aspetta che devo capire ok a molto
che ci fa un po un casino però lo fece
lions ok ed acqua ok qua qua qua c'è un
blocco diverse non c'entra niente
hai capito bravissimo il bravissimo
perfetto allora vedo il blocco per
schiacciare prendere l'ultimo livello e
ma però lo meglio del diamante sei fatta
di sì però non vedo diamante nascosta
800 più sopra è stata la domanda lo so
vediamo
per adesso non lo non lo sto proprio
trovando però vabbè non importa ma
neanch'io ma guarda che l'ha veramente
nascosto ma il fatto è questo troviamo
amen è il livello dove più l'abbiamo
cercato e non abbia trovato in atto
ma c'è una scaletta easy bellissimo
giretto anno di qualità di qualche e poi
devo fare l'ultimo pare che si provano
arrivo la somma con questo livello
madonna quali rischi di cadere no amico
mio amico aspetta oddio qua allora sul
finale rischi di cadere nel livello
prima ce l'ho fatta mica ce l'ho fatta
sono fatte sua fatta ti prego ti prego
vieni viri quali qua vi voglio vederti
evidentemente questa cosa voglio vederti
proviene vieni vieni amico vai mai non
voglio dai ma se ti pro finisco qui il
parkour io mai venir la lisi male bravo
in grado ma mi sono fermato ho fermato
me stesso perché ho avuto una voglia
aveva una voglia di fare così che era
incredibile guarda ma proprio tantissimo
mi sono trattenuto in una maniera che
non puoi capire comunque ragazzi l'esca
proprio lui livello 6 rai a michele sei
amiche siamo nell'ultimo livello oggi si
chiama nenè ter ovvero spero sia certo
ma non funziona più da funzionari brussa
tesi e scassato no no smettila sua
maestà in comparendo ma come è vero che
c'è stato sto facendo il parkour portava
e sei caduto e sono caduto bacinetto
amici e porti già amiche mentre vai
parkour fortissimo sono i tuoi grazie
all evil 6 bienne è comparso adesso è
solo schiacciato compare ha messo lo
schiaccio io comparate ma buona 0 ma
fatto sta roba ma smettila va sarà nacci
che non vedono un balzo difficoltà di un
team a pasta filata non è successo
niente dà per fatto credere ma no è una
volta solo è successo allora dài allora
essendo l'ultimo immagino sia il più
difficile è già così che comunque poi
prima se noti alla fine non abbiamo
trovato diamante esatto mai mancare
bougherra era sotto la lava si 3.000 per
cento che sarà sotto da lato lo giuro
sulla finale non quella iniziale fidati
era quello sicuro non lo so io visione
guarda io un po cercato è però non trovo
nulla mi ha detto buon magari avanti
magari avanti che poi non c'è un ok
attenzione bravo bravo
o c'e nulla no allora herat è veramente
i difficilissimo cioè quello il fatto
cioè non c'è bisogno di pagare proprio
un casino bravissimo e adesso adesso
girati bravissimo sopra pd deve fare
destra destra sopra di ritrovare dov'eri
tu prima presente no no prima prima
prima il primo nel piller a quella lì ok
è bravo ma sei sicuro di questo
e ora fa gli slam jam passo qui sotto
yes e ora un bravissimo perché di
centrarlo è veramente non di saltare
tutto si salti tutto avanti
finisci oltre finisce che ci stavo
finendo e l'incredibile dove una donna
scuse che vada a questi che vorrebbe
ricavare gli altri dove era fini ci
arrivavamo lo stesso allora qua te lo
dico e belli sopra michela si vede non
capito io ho pensato di fare esatto vai
lì e poi ti rifai lo slime sul costo
alto no non penso tra lo slime non dire
nulla serviva al mese riva lo slang
effettivamente ha o no in realtà serviva
era solo per prende per il culo
ok alla seduta non lo so se serve lo
stai più perché ci mettiamo vent'anni da
river è un h ma porca vacca è un casino
è lo so perché ma non sia pronostico si
trova per ora ci prova c
ma non posso che mi sembrano ce l'ha
fatta a mordente ma già amiche forte
dove cacchio va ho capito slime è esatto
ma tu spetta poi vado io però e mikado
guarda come cadeau bravo bravissimo
bravo programma vi dico perché
ma arriviamo così la ies kamal jazz
mamma mia che paura cerca cerca il
diamante lordo cercato sto cercando la
picanto sta cercando di vedere se ci
sono possibile possiamo salire senza
facilita la mappa questo è abbastanza
questo è strano perché di fare così
no no no no onore no lo re
hai visto tu devi fare ha quindi ok
quindi se stavamo fermi all'inizio cazzo
attenzione non andare troppo in là e di
salotto no io ho poverissimo dove stava
bene farlo piano
diretta durante ogni prima il gip che
cosa devo fare costo domandarvi per
forza non avevo no vabbè no ma se da
questo pupazzi ma sono pazzi come puoi
non è da devi fare una cosa incredibile
questo non è vero se non ci credono
scusami non è altissimo però devi farlo
bene bravo forte fortissima vabbè che
cazzo ne va bene ciao mikè no no io non
bevo no forse diranno guarda quella
parola qua è una patetica pillar devo
provo si prova ci ormai mica un fenomeno
incredibile bravo occhio 266 no non è
ricaduto totalmente non so perché vabbè
il crimine assurda sta roba aversi stato
bravissimo
grazie e arriviamo fila sopra grazie
proprio a chi sei dare l'ultimo saluto a
questo rumore che già mostrava i su
barche saranno ricci insieme a far qui
sotto questo messaggio che sta sopra
dove sarà ok che liquida è finita è
finita è finita è finita champions
league tutti quanti come facciamo a ok
anche voi ritorni indietro emilia e tu
come fai michetti cioè fino alla
prossima
leggo che tutto questo non c'è
studiamo aveva domato la gloria ma dalla
gloria alla gloria beh questo è facile
per questo è facile
questo è facile easy life hanno fatto
però sarà finale dall'attenzione che la
fede ma aspettiamo un attimo c'è poi la
tensione mi ha dato check point vuol
dire che questo è un bordello amiche sei
adesso c'è poi il labor dello c'è una
barba jato sinistra ma la sua destra
scusa di mezzo va in mezzo
bravo e scendi giu c'è un blocchetto
scegli tu mi vuoi far buttare noi c'è un
blocchetto davanti a decine di giorni un
blocchetto non quello bravo quello che
dietro di te dietro i temi come basso
diciamo che ti basso c'è un blocco in
basso di lubianka esatto scendi scendi
guarda in basso al seggio a sinistra e
basso a sinistra
eccolo che l'ultimo tutte le altre c'è
domanda che ho preso la mia voce pio iv
peccato per questo 64 il demonio come
saluto ma quello è facilissimo ok hai
capito
ma c'è un check point aspetta ma aspetto
ma tv in diamanti anni ho paura che non
vuoi dirmela domando perché no no no
sono caduto come un pirla maledetto sa
bene che lo facciamo insieme arrivato
qua qua sopra e poi ho qua è un casino
perché non ho capito ancora aspetta ok
ok non avere paura di andare molto oltre
quanto c'è il blocco
ok è perduto ok ok
ma dollari blacks con madonna rega
madonna riga incredibile ma se ne va
bene va bene va bene possibile ora
quello come cazzo come cosa già fatta
non ci credono che cosa è pazzesco fatto
incredibile deve bene senza un altro
quando guarda quando ci fa arrivare ma
su 9 assurdo problema di poter accorgi
ok ok mi guardi liquami che vi dico
amico a vedi qua ti aspetta sistematico
a fa qui sopra ferma guarda soprattutto
ok bravo guarda guardia dobbiamo fare
qualcosa vedi dove il finale laggiù dove
doveva prima donna incredibile con calma
e con calma tutte d'un fiato lo facciamo
questo ok bravissimo questa era un altro
fiato quando i piatti gioco fortissimo è
un questo difficile ma pazzesco papa
ridicolo pazzesco pazzesco paesi questo
ok coeva stanza easing ok nice
e non ci sono checkpoint amiche come non
parlare di nomine per cento lo giuro non
ci sono se poi questo non davanti jolo
male ho fatti 14 sono fuori di simo sono
forti ma io ci credo ci vado mamma mia
quanto ci credo mamma mi ha fatto forte
nove ragazzi assurdo insomma al primo al
primo giro assurdo incredibile e si
prosegue è una donna dove non fatti
stiamo cadendo 26 a michele bravo ma
dono ragazzi pazzesco è questo
impossibile tonico già arrivati anche il
tasto proponeva che uncharted possa
schiacciare questo sia salvata lo ha
schiacciato piccola ne so che ci fa lo
stesso con lo stesso ma è un cazzo sei
tu sopra guarda in aria
che cacchio fai ed i ragazzi questa era
parkour strikes si chiama
giusto la bellissima mi è piaciuto
moltissimo veramente bello veramente
ragazzi io spero che video vi sia
piaciuto cosi facendo mi piace e vi
ringrazio l'avesse di 3.000 fate i suoi
soprattutto parkour di 10 episodi almeno
molto più grande di questo molto più
difficile molto più dove io pietro
ricorderemo che erano strana amicizia
che dura noi come sempre ci vediamo
l'anno prossimo video bella ragazzi
[Musica]
no